I was very thrilled to get a telegram
from fake Kane and then president of the
Motion Picture Academy saying that I had
won the Student Academy Award he got up
on my bed and I was jumping up and down
on my bed I remember looking at the list
of other people who had won awards and
Spike Lee was a few years ahead of me
and I remember thinking wow that's
somebody who won the same award he was a
student just like me and look where he
went tonight we're here to see the best
student films in the country and honor
the filmmakers we've flown the winning
students in from across the country they
spent the last few days meeting
professionals filmmakers and seeing the
way we make movies in Hollywood but
after seeing their movies boy do we have
something to learn we had a great week I
mean the people I was with all the
filmmakers were terrific great week of
activities camaraderie and bonding we
had a little ceremony where we came to
the Academy theater and I was given the
award by Billy freaking so it was a
great day I showed up I had a real ugly
white suit like Saturday Night Fever I
am glad you like it yeah
it was a pretty amazing thing Robby
Benson was the presenter and I had hair
that was like his tall as my head and I
I wore a bright red suit and the flashes
going off everywhere and I was like this
is crazy I I was thrilled it's this is
the one I wanted to win more than
anything so it was a great moment I
would introduce to you John Lasseter
whose head is full of magical nonsense
I'm so happy the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences has student
county roads because student films are
so important students are approaching
things from such a different perspective
and I think they oftentimes have really
fresh interesting things to say and it
was a huge encouragement to me the
Student Academy Award actually really
validated my instincts as a filmmaker
and I realized that even then as a
student that we all had the same
challenges and we all face the same
problems the Student Academy Awards our
way the industry gives back and away the
industry supports and nurtures the
newcomers to have a pseudonym II award
on your resume certainly gave you a
magnificent cachet and and and and
helped open doors here in the industry
for sure I was lucky enough to have
someone look at my student film and he's
standing right here and help to give me
a break in the in the industry if you
can be recognized by this Academy it's
it really says something for you let to
the door of this mythic organization
it's like you've stepped into oz or
through the looking glass I've got two
Academy Awards I've got some Emmys I got
a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame you
know all these great prizes that I've
won but the two student having words are
two of the things that are most proud of
because they were the first things that
I want and
they gave me confidence they kind of
told me that the films that came from
your heart your mind your taste your
talent is good it's entertaining because
the future of the film industry is with
our new artist
I